money's tight for everybody you know
everybody wants to upgrade to the newest
coolest thing and we've allowed people
to trade in their older weapons
motorcycles and other things of value
towards their latest purchase
I said if I got a deal for you each has
a cash value but each has a value to us
and that's what counting because when he
left he was smiling when I left are
smiling it's just another medium of
exchange
it ended up going from one hand to
another to another all based on the
value we all put on it there's a few
times I've done some trading where I
stopped the trade you know I just didn't
want to make the deal I didn't feel
comfortable about it I'm not you know
some guy says I don't know I'm gonna
scare that no I'm not making a deal with
this sketchy and you're uncomfortable
with it it all depends on where your
moral compass goes right